hello my name is baby Chappell and I'm
here at the 2014 GQ Man of the Year
shoot I were never funny what I'm doing
with my life first of all I thank you
for that question because it makes the
assumption that I am funny but I agree
if I wasn't funny as a hypothetical and
my publicist once told me wisely never
answer a hypothetical but waste the most
time my career wastes the most time of
anything that's not good that's not true
what was the most surprising thing don't
ten shows in Radio City first of all
that they were all sold out haven't
played New York in like 12 years so that
was very pleasant surprise
second of all the most surprising thing
would have been Kanye West showing up
unscheduled unannounced it was just
there the spirit moved them the guy was
stage and he did three songs it was very
kind and it was really great
there would be mos def being in the
United States I know that he was able to
get back into the country I'd heard
things a plan Radio City was on my
comedy bucket list I'd say that's one
thing that was very difficult and I was
very happy to do and I don't know if
that will ever happen again if I had the
sum of this year and a single phrase
that phrase would be midlife crisis well
there's several things that I'd want to
do that no GQ Man of the Year has ever
done one of wishes I would like to go
back to television and be the first
black man to have sex Olivia Pope on
scandal this is my question okay what
comes with being GQ man in the year sure
I'll be in the magazine which
which is very huge accomplishment what
do I get
can I go around for the rest of the year
and say that I am currently the reigning
man of the year laughter they speak at
schools like Miss America hi kids I'm
Jake he's mad at me
study hard and you can bawl like me
minute since I'm just kidding our own
offices thank you for watching and God
bless
[Music]